though ambitious ladies are back I love
this story I love this season what does
it mean to both of you to have season
three of this show and these characters
we're really stoked we had a really good
time shooting this season although it
feels like a blur we can't really
remember what happened I am NOT a
prostitute I'm a comic is there a
difference yes
prostitutes get paid more hilarious you
should go into comedy I did it was I
think some growing pains in some way
both for us and the characters yeah but
but those are usually the best
experiences what do you mean this Susie
and midge have to do a lot of growing
together and a part on this in this
season we were thrown into a lot of new
situations as seeds in a lot of new
places and new audiences from different
places and that was true for us and the
characters you see the world
the audience is when they're great are
really great and you're not having to go
to your grave not having done anything
interesting what do you think the secret
sauce of this show is why is it that
everyone is like patiently waiting until
they can binge the show you're gonna be
so proud of me I was gonna say something
filthy and I edited it I am so I got to
do a special sauce here I'll uh well we
I mean who knows honestly at the end of
the day but we talked a lot about how
you know work we're here in this one
where there's so much good TV and what's
cool about being on this show is that
there's so many different ways in for
different people
[Laughter]
special I mean I think the the chemistry
between a lot of characters is what
what's special you've got it with with
Rachael and Tony and you've got with
Tony and Mara and and Rachael and I and
there's there's interesting there's
interesting plus minuses with everyone
everything makes it mix sparks fly
they'll always be my number one
I love hearing from different people
what their ways and have been you know
there's people who relate to Tony and
Marv in these characters to the parents
and those people who relate to midge
people are so frustrated by midge but I
love watching her people who feel more
like a Suzy yeah people who feel like
Michael vegan who feel like a Joel and
what most people all agree I'm hating
little more redeeming in this season a
little bit yeah I know he is I mean he's
he's pursuing his own dream life yeah
but people do forget that you know
things that he blew yep he was lousy
it's not always his fault people talk
about how midge blew up everyone's lives
but really we have to remember it was
Joel at that then at the end of the day
I stepped up I'm here oh and I'm not
you're in Florida so your relationship
is sort of the heart of this show and it
is true that as stars rise in show
business they sort of leave their baby
managers and then get signed by the
big-name person who also manages
Jennifer Lopez or whatever you do in
Hollywood what growing pains will be see
and do you guys remember your first
managers no but you I'm gonna make it
such a big star talking about the Emmys
I wanted Amy I fired you yeah that
should get rid of everyone your big star
after this we've lunch break okay
perfect
this is the big leagues kid got to start
at like a rentals
so Dean Meyerson remember the face is
freezing I remember the face these guys
went through a lot of growing pains
yes season mijin Suzy they went on on
the mini road for the first time and
they got to know each other really well
well in a short period of time and that
involves its own kind of growing pains
you're exactly right that now it's a
different ballgame that they're that
they're playing being on 12 is shy is is
huge and is a huge stepping stone and
and and both of them also have other
things going on yes their lives and
their personal and professional lives
and those things will be at odds with
each other at times and it's very
unlikely handle morning first of a
million tours
when is Suzy getting a love life um
that's what will happen this season I
want to spoil it for anyone but don't
Suzy and babe kind of I shouldn't you
did whaler I am for the first time in my
life taking charge of my own destiny
well that can end badly at all no I
guess my white question going into this
third season is because we thought you
might have any love and then you got
back patrol and then I mean speaking
like it's management obviously it's not
and I guess it's like can a woman have a
great career and a great romance at the
same time there's that possible it's one
of the big questions you know and I
think people in a lot of different
careers but certainly in this one in
show business of all kinds are faced
with and Midge has made a decision at
the end of season 2 that she feels like
you can't that's what she says you know
I'm gonna be alone for the rest of my
life I'm deciding to take that path I
realize now that that's the only way to
have the kind of career I want to have
she learned to the course of season 2
that that your personal life suffers and
that that's always gonna be the
sacrifice that she has to make I don't
know if I believe that that's true but
there is and we've talked about this a
lot there's no such thing as balance
really opening for shy was theoretical
before now
I'm really nervous you're gonna be great
I think that the cruel thing that the
world does society does is present that
expectation to women yet like you know
that's one of your questions is she
gonna be able to have a love life too
and it's like is that key is that
important right
who cares what is that you know what
does that mean and can you be fulfilled
romantically in other ways can you find
romance in your career can you the
feeling you get on the stage can be
better than any intimate relationship it
is an intimate relationship it just
sometimes with 3,000 people in a room
but but yeah I think sometimes the
questions a disservice to women in
particular that you might even need that
yeah that you that you might need to be
pursuing having it all to have it all
yeah maybe maybe that's an illusion and
maybe that's okay it's your girl gonna
get good she is gonna be a goddamn
legend not to put you on the spot but I
did see a recent Instagram post and I do
want to ask you who's your favorite
co-star between Rachel and Halle Berry
oh god they're so similar
my favorite co-star like what do they
each bring to the table that's maybe the
same or different or you know like
they're both stunning yes they're both
stunningly beautiful and they're both
very very difficult yes very very I mean
the egos they're really the same person
I never thought about it before my god
I mean area very similar allergies you
know Halle and I worked on a film
together for a specific period of time
so it's very different like you you know
reaches his family this is yeah this is
like a long-term long-term relationship
they like it Halle was a one-night stand
[Music]